ils étaient réunis hier à versailles
cinq présidents de départements
franciliens donnait une réunion publique
au palais des congrès en présence de
gérard larcher président du sénat les
yvelines l'essonne la seine-et-marne le
val d'oise et les hauts-de-seine
souhaite une métropole du grand paris
régionale créée en 2016 elle regroupe
pour le moment la capitale et la petite
couronne exclusivement sans le reste de
l'ile-de-france et d'ici un mois le
gouvernement pourrait faire des annonces
sur la métropole un périmètre identique
avec une disparition des départements du
92 du 93 et du 94 cents à intégrer la
grande couronne francilienne
il ya ce sujet nous avons pu interroger
sur place hier le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines ainsi que
celui des oeufs des yvelines de pierre
bédier pardon ainsi que celui à des
hauts-de-seine patrick devedjian il on a
répondu aux questions de mélanie poker
et de nicolas kirillovitch deuxième
opération d'envergure organisée par les
départements franciliens quelques jours
seulement après la conférence de presse
organisée à paris le 10 octobre
plusieurs départements français les élus
locaux se sont unies ici au palais des
congrès à versailles
objectif évidemment donner une nouvelle
fois votre avis sur l'avenir de la
métropole du grand paris car bédié
patrick devidjian merci de répondre à
nos questions première peut-être
question il ya dix jours vous étiez 7
aujourd'hui vous êtes moins nombreux
pourquoi pierre bédier
on n'est pas moins nombreux il y avait
800 personnes dans la salle et nous
manquions que c'est géré mais j'ai
évoqué les présidents des départements
bien entendu
à cette occasion ce sont les présidents
de conseil départemental de droite et du
centre qui se sont réunis et en juin
dans une ils étaient tous là dans une
réunion qui devait être à l'origine une
réunion pédagogique de nos deux
départements 78 92 pour parler de notre
projet de fusion est naturellement
stéphane troussel et favier de christian
favier par d'anjou a oublié son prénom
pouvait pas aller jusqu'à participer à
une réunion publique de cette nature
mais sur le fond nous sommes d'accord
comme ils vont en vie la semaine
dernière donc sur le fond sans comprend
bien le message qui était portée
nouvelle fois ce soir c'est de vous
souhaiter une métropole du grand paris
et de la région ile de france sont
d'accord pour rejeter la frontière qui
est établie par la loi ou jaune donc une
métropole élargi aux périmètres delà de
la région ile-de-france mais du coup
quelques elle quel avenir pour cette
pour cette région ile de france il y a
deux entités deux collectivités de la
même taille
est-ce que ça fera pas un échelon de
trop et si oui lequel faudra supprimer
je pense qu'il faut raisonner en bloc
plutôt que de vouloir supprimer
vous avez le bloc communal qui est le
bloc qui répond aux préoccupations
quotidiennes des habitants
il est essentiel les élus les habitants
des dizaines leur mère ils aiment leur
commune ils en ont besoin et avec le
partenaire indispensable quelle
intercommunalité pour ces communes et
puis vous avez ce que nous ont créé que
le bloc métropolitaine qui est à
l'échelle de la région et qui englobe
donc les tous les départements est
l'émanation de tous ces départements
avec la métropole ça donne le bloc
contre pétain et là on importe des
services de proximité mais aussi des
services un peu plus stratégique
on met plus de moyens humains défi
donc on répond pas à cette problématique
connue de la région ile-de-france en
tout cas de la métropole parisienne du
millefeuille territorial sept mille
feuille territorial c'est une blague
le millefeuille territorial c'est l'état
qu il a créée en 1999 ils ont créé
l'intercommunalité en 2015 ils ont créé
la métropole
il y avait trois étages ils en ont fait
cinq bons mais eux
en même temps ils ont créé mille deux
cent soixante dix agences d'état c'est à
dire que c'est pas milf est un chou à la
crème
vous avez qu'est ce que vous dit
concrètement est-ce que vous avez des
contacts directement avec le
gouvernement le président de la
république vous vous êtes opposés au
projet actuel les rumeurs vous le disiez
vous même dans la presse ou un tapis
d'une métropole qui se fixerait à la
petite couronne plus certains
territoires de la couronne est ce que
vous faisiez vous de la presse est-ce
que ce qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que du
coup vous êtes encore optimiste est-ce
que vous avez des informations positives
sur vos sur leur requête à vous alors
peu importe que les informations soient
bonnes ou mauvaises
nous sommes optimistes par nature et on
se bat pas ce que c'est pour nous une
telle évidence qu'on ne peut pas séparer
la grande couronne de la petite couronne
pourquoi ne pas aussi s installer comme
on le faisait entre l'allemagne de l'est
et l'allemagne de l'ouest des
checkpoints donc pour passer avec lui
mais ça c'est là pour passer dans les
hauts-de-seine honorait checkpoint
il faudrait présenter un papier
d'identité enfin tout ça tout ça est
grotesque à une époque on nous parle de
mondialisation où on nous parle de
d'élargir nos horizons
en france on veut réduire le réseau et
construire des murs là où de toute
évidence il faut essayer d'être beaucoup
plus large beaucoup plus rassembleur
beaucoup plus dynamique et surtout
préoccupés par le développement
économique de ce qu'on explique avec
patrick depuis le début notre projet de
fusion de départements
il est d'abord centrée sur cette idée
qu'il faut produire de la richesse pour
pouvoir la partager et que c'est la
condition sinequanone on finira j'espère
par faire entendre
ce bon sens si je ne l'entends pas la
france perdra encore quelques années et
l'île de france super beau et si ce
message je n'ai pas entendu du coup quel
quel avenir pour la fusion 78,92 ça sera
du coup un projet a oubliées
concrètement c'est impossible de le
réaliser un énorme pierre bédier moi
nous sommes des gens tenaces et
rassurez-vous le combat contre la vie
politique c'est ça parfois on met très
longtemps pour faire aboutir
quelque chose d'important et
d'intelligence mais totalement
l'intelligence c'est un peu comme un
bouchon de liège quand vous le tenez
avec une main de fer au fond de l'eau by
remontent pas mais le jour où la main
s'en trouve le bouchon remonte donc ça
arrive à une dernière question pour le
département des yvelines supposons que
la métropole reste dans le schéma actuel
est ce que vous êtes inquiet pour
l'avenir du département concrètement à
court terme n'ont rien ne changera sauf
si naturellement l'état continue à nous
saigner parce que les collectivités
locales sont encore appelé à des efforts
substantiels que l'état ne s'appliquent
pas lui-même mais c'est un autre débat
mais je suis à ikea moyens et surtout à
long terme la volonté de l'état de
concentrer le département
une partie du territoire en ignorant une
autre partie du territoire elle et
pardonnez-moi si le mot en chant que
certains parce qu'il paraît très
excessif mais les criminels parce que
bien entendu il y aura moins de richesse
aujourd'hui des yvelines qu'est ce que
c'est une zone urbaine dynamique qui
partage sa richesse par le biais du
département avec une zone rurale dont
l'économie est moins dynamique et c'est
normal ce qu'on ne demande pas la zone
rurale et être en production de
richesses on lui demande d'être notre
notre facteur qualité de vie que de
monde nous envie c'est cet équilibre qui
fait la force des huiles et cet
équilibre est gravement menacée par
cette métropole réduite aux acquêts
merci messieurs pour vos réponses
complet sur ce sujet le président du
groupe les républicains et indépendants
au conseil régional d'ile-de-france
othman nassr ou appellent aujourd'hui à
une fusion de la région est de la
métropole du grand paris elle yvelinois
demande au gouvernement de tenir compte
de la réalité du terrain
une fusion permettrait de supprimer un
échelon administratif trop nombreux en
france selon l'élu